hey was geht ab und herzlich willkommen
zu einem neuen video leute ich hoffe
natürlich jedes gut ich habe mir gedacht
ich würde gerne mal das günstigste land
europas mit dem teuersten land europas
vergleichen und dazu bin ich vor einiger
zeit mal für zwei drei tage nach
bulgarien geflogen letzte woche letzte
woche zu woche ja letzte woche dann aber
auch für zwei tage in die schweiz
genauer gesagt nach zürich so eigentlich
der teuersten stadt europas mein plan
ist es gewesen einmal von 50 euro einen
tag lang in bulgarien zu leben zu
schauen was bekommt man da und auch noch
ein tag für 50 euro in der schweiz
beziehungsweise in zürich zu leben wir
starten jetzt gleich mit bulgarien rein
und danach kommt dann die schweiz und es
wird glaube ich echt ziemlich
interessant was ich noch kurz dazu sagen
möchte und zwar ging es mir in erster
linie ganz normal einen tag in der stadt
zu leben als wäre ich so tourist ich
mein man checkt ein paar restaurants
aber man geht mal ein bierchen trinken
man geht ein eis essen was auch immer
und nicht jetzt in der schweiz im
supermarkt zu gehen zuschauern was
kostet eine tiefkühlpizza er kostet
übrigens sieben schweizer franken so
wurde mir das gesagt geistes kann
zumindest die guten pizzen also
umgerechnet auch so ungefähr sieben euro
und das dann halt mit supermärkten in
bulgarien zu vergleichen also das habe
ich nicht gemacht ihren einfachen tag
entspannt in der stadt verbracht in den
jeweiligen städten bisschen rum gegangen
ein bisschen die stadt erkundet und
sowas war halt für mich auch viel cooler
und interessanter deswegen wollen wir
gar nicht eingeladen und starten direkt
mal rein mit ich habe so gesehen dann
einmal 50 euro in bulgarien abgehoben
und hatte umgerechnet 97 bulgarische
lämmer und natürlich auch 50 euro in der
schweiz und hatte hier ungefähr 53
schweizer franken für diesen tag zur
verfügung wir hatten in bulgarien dem
hotel mit frühstück und ich habe auch an
dem tag im hotel gefrühstückt deswegen
fiel das frühstück weg und dann ging es
für mich direkt zum friseur da gibt es
auch schon ein video von also das letzte
video wahrheit von ihrem friseur hab ich
ein bisschen mehr mitgefilmt aber ganz
kurz noch mal aussieht davon
56 laver der nummer draußen weil alles
gut aber noch das war nämlich auch an
diesem 50 euro tag und ich dachte mir
kommen nimmt das einfach mit rein weil
ich werde auch am ende sehen was so
weiter also meine haare sind jetzt
wirklich sehr sehr radikal geworden aber
kein problem die wachsen danach ist die
küche und zeigst dich mal rheinländer
990 haircut also das ist schon wirklich
enorm günstig muss ich sagen und danach
sind wir auf jeden fall erstmal die
stadt gegangen wir sind über diese
kaffeeautomaten er ist es das cappuccino
für 570 levels
sogar ein stäbchen mit drin wir haben
uns erst mal noch zwei verspätete
cappuccinos gezogen ganz wichtig noch
kurze erklärung beide zusammen 1,4 liter
gekostet was umgerechnet ungefähr 70
cent ist also pro cappuccino 35 cent
kann man nicht mehr kann ein leute
werden geradezu wochenrunde leim scooter
zu fahren auf geht's oder also in
deutschland zahlt für die einsperrung
über neuro hier kostet das 120 läufer ab
60 cent ungefähr in bulgarien sind die
eigentlich nur taxi gefahren weil es so
unfassbar günstig gewesen ist dann
wollten wir nämlich ein eis essen gehen
und uns richtig ein hinter die rüstung
römern
canaries
[Musik]
wir haben mal wieder hier jetzt für wie
lange wir gefahren 10-15 minuten
456 bezahlt
also umgerechnet zwei euro 30 ca krank
dann ging es in wirklich neues
restaurant und da gab es alles zu recht
guten preisen fairen preisen muss ich
sagen so leute wir sind uns im
restaurant gegangen und habe jetzt erst
mal dicke gästen wir haben hier auf
jeden fall verschiedene sachen das hier
sieht schon richtig geil aus 14 meter
also ungefähr fünf euro im burger 12
leber wir können es uns hier richtig gut
gehen das beziehungsweise ich mir auch
schon nutzen schaffen
also zwei euro kann man nicht meckern
war ich würde ja in deutschland
alkoholiker werden ich bin ja gerade bei
einem 50 euro video ich habe so viel
budget heute noch über ich auf jeden
fall zu bringen können kann ich dir
gerne spendieren würde heute meinen es
los dann sagst du zum salat
gewarnt
als wir hier im restaurant waren war es
schon ungefähr 17 uhr wir hatten so ein
leicht verspätetes frühstück und dann
irgendwie nicht mehr so wirklich hunger
also das war die erste richtige mahlzeit
an diesem tag und ihr könnt hier unten
sehen es war so unfassbar schwer das
ganze geld loszuwerden die top 4 euro
und selbst ausgehen dass schon rein
oder auch 60 lang war zu dem zeitpunkt
war es eigentlich noch 36 euro oder so
da habe ich mich ein bisschen verrechnet
müssten wir schon ordentlich über
trinken oder
solche die an nummer zwei und nachspeise
gibt schon einen leckeren brownie und
motel alasania aber das zählt ja nicht
bei mir nur dass hier sind ungefähr
350 fünf euro 50 mit dir zusammen
dieser laden hier happy war super leute
wirklich wenn jemand hier in sofia
zeitpunkt ab
luca ist ein wirklich kann man nur nach
oben gehen ich habe umgerechnet für das
abendessen zwei bier nachspeise und ein
gutes leckeres essen 12 euro bezahlt
oder 13 euro mit trinkgeld also das war
wirklich sehr krass so lala bull alarm
wenn wir nach bulgarien fahren
[Musik]
warum haben wir dann so viel gesoffen er
wie viel bier habe ich danach drückten
auch und hier noch als hinweis ich habe
leon also meinen kumpel dann schon
eingeladen immer wir hatten hier zwei
bier und ein großes wasser irgendwie
schon fast unter dass wir wir sind ja
wirklich durchgesteckt leute wir sind
hier in einer bierbar das bier ist jetzt
fast voll und es kostet umgerechnet so
hier haben wir richtig also hier habe
ich ein bisschen mehr bezahlt ich kann
euch mal die rechnungen einblenden wir
haben dazu zwei zu ungefähr fünf bier
getrunken 505 bier für umgerechnet dann
zehn euro
also 20 lieber habe ich bezahlt für uns
beide zusammen dann hat sie auch erst
mal gereicht bekam etf würde ich mal
sagen das ist muss hier auch mal
probieren
wir hätten wegfallen können kann man
seinen schlüssel steckt
naja hier hat man auf jeden fall schon
gemerkt dass der abend ganz gut war und
dann sind wir zurück ins hotel mit taxi
für 720 und dann waren wir auch im bett
was in der ganzen rechnung nicht
enthalten war aber trinkgeld natürlich
hat die junge über ein bisschen trinker
gegeben und das waren ungefähr dann zehn
leather also hatte ich am ende aber
immer noch 11,5 bulgarische lämmer übrig
und wir hatten echt ein super abend ihr
habt ja gemerkt was ich alles bezahlt
habe das war echt jede menge und dann
irgend ein paar tage später ab in die
schweiz leute was geht ab ich irre hier
gerade durch die gassen von zürich leute
ich treffe mich hier nämlich jetzt
gleich mit dem lohr ist freue ich mich
schon drauf dann habe ich mich schon
echt lange nicht mehr gesehen und ich
habe es gerade mal ausgerechnet ich habe
heute 53 schweizer franken zur verfügung
das sind umgerechnet nämlich genau 50
euro und ich bin mal gespannt wie weit
du damit kommen ich glaube nicht soweit
hier ohne scheiß ich wollte gerade eben
am bahnhof auf klo gehen einfach schon
zwei schweizer franken dafür in
deutschland kostet 70 sein und noch ganz
lustig ich bleibe euch mal sprach nach
richtigen von loris okay also was das
lustige ist wenn du vom flughafen zu mir
fährst du schon 50 schweizer franken
ich glaube die wissen weniger also
werden gleich auf jeden fall mal was
essen gehen und hier den tag verbringen
ich bin wirklich gespannt was hier so
alles geht die polizei ist ja einfach
orange ich denke dass der rettungsdienst
war hier so schön als müsse normalen
lobes finden lohr ist und ich habe mir
auf jeden fall genau den richtigen tag
ausgesucht alter die sonne ball hat hier
so wir haben jetzt auf jeden fall 100
schweizer franken ich konnte nicht
weniger abheben eigentlich wollte ich
nur 55 haben ich muss auch sagen ich
weiß nicht mehr ob es fünf ein schweizer
franken gilt auf jeden fall müssen davon
am ende noch 47 schweizer franken über
bleiben und dann ist das ding hier durch
ja mal schauen ich bin s bahn toilette
was geht ab ich bin jetzt mittlerweile
hier mit loris gut dass du dir zeit
genommen hat übrigens das war ein
bisschen spontan oder es ging ja
und ich habe ja gesagt was die form ich
habe jetzt 53 schweizer franken für
heute hier mitgebracht die ich ausgeben
darf ich lade ich auch gern mal ein aber
ich kann ihn nicht einladen und wir
gucken wie weit wir kommen damit mit 53
zu fragen
danke für die einladung
ok ich muss sagen ich hab hunger wir
haben schon fast wieder nach 12 uhr
schon und wir gehen es etwas kannst du
ja und dann schauen wir mal wie viel
davon noch über bleiben also in
bulgarien bin ich den ganzen tag aus
gekommen und ich habe glaube ich habe
ende nicht nur 50 euro bezahlt also
längst nicht wir sind taxi gefahren als
50 euro ist ihr trinkt also
ich bin froh dass hier nicht wohnen okay
let's go leute bis gleich gibts ja was
typisch schweizerisches romberger super
was wird zu schätzen wie viel geld wenn
ich gleich los nach dem essen heraus
wenn es nicht zu übertreiben dann würde
ich mal sagen 30 franken 30 franken euro
in bulgarien habe ich für eine
hauptspeise mit bisher zwei bis zwölf
euro bezahlt ist ein
hot 9 eur 406 basic es gibt ja noch
andere
ohne scheiß die preise da sind so
gestört so ein hotdog das kostet bei uns
hier in deutschland keine ahnung drei
euro fünfzig oder so da kostet einfach
fast zehn euro das ist so krank teuer da
ist das hätte ich nicht gedacht also
ohne scheiß die leute verdienen dazu
auch viel mehr als wir hier aber da war
echt also ich war geschockt
freeski
küche ein käsefondue es nicht teuer hier
nehme das nur weil da ja genau ich
dachte wirklich ja so ein bisschen
aufgeheizter käse kann ja nicht teuer
sein dann waren es einfach nur beilagen
und dieses hauptgericht 30 schweizer
franken also fast 30 euro für so ein
bisschen käse von
30 franken für eine person 200 gramm
also leute wären wir jetzt mal platz
genommen logos möchte unbedingt so einen
käse fondue essen
das kostet schon mal 30 franken plus bei
lage sind es elf bei 37 euro pro person
dann und dann noch ein getränk dann ist
der tag ja schon gelaufen für mich also
ich habe wirklich gedacht das ist teuer
wird hier in zürich aber das ist so
teuer wird
hätte ich vielleicht nicht was hast du
geschätzt also hätte das gedacht ich
zahle ja so 20 mehr als in deutschland
hätte er ja es ist ja doppel 100 prozent
mehr ja dann auch zürich würde ich
sowieso leute loris hat ihr das
käsefondue sich gegönnt
tschuldigung ich habe hier die spitze
das sieht richtig lecker aus aber er hat
auch seinen preis guten hunger dir und
ich das hier noch durchziehen
also rückwirkend
25 90 für spätzle
wenn es in bulgarien spätzle geben würde
wie teuer werden die vielleicht 79 90
oder so raus aus dem restaurant mainz
hat ungefähr mit trinkgeld 34 oder 35
schweizer franken gekostet ich bin euch
den genauen preis mal hier ein also ich
habe jetzt noch so ungefähr 20 17
überstehen hier mal die teuren autos
warum bist du nicht mit auto
wir gehen jetzt ein eis essen dann würde
ich gern noch ein bier trinken und ich
glaube dann ist vorbei leider das ja
traurig und wir können auch hinkommen
was kostet hier eine kugel für
frankreich eine fucking kugel eis vier
haltet euch fest leute wenn ihr aus
deutschen und vier franken 30 für eine
kugel eis als ich noch ein kleiner junge
war da war ich hier bei mir im dorf
immer eine eisdiele 40 cent zehnmal so
teuer zehn mal so ich bin ich bin es
draußen geblieben alex ist gerade drin
und günstig da ich weiß nicht wie viele
kugeln nimmt aber wir gleich raus kommen
sagen das ist so zu tun
viele hast du die zahl 18 euro
14482 kugeln ich weine mit waffen leute
acht schweizer franken 40 für dieses
aber ist es hier so schön loris da kann
ich darüber weg sehen aber das ist also
meiner meinung nach ist das eine
frechheit einmal schlucken zähnchen er
läutet dann habe ich noch zwei bier
verloren sich gekauft für den rückweg im
zug knapp acht schweizer franken und der
rest sind da noch übrig war und in der
ecke das wahl trinkgeld in dem
restaurant wo wir gegessen haben und
dann waren die 50 euro auch schon weg
das ging wirklich schneller als ich
gucken konnte in bulgarien gab es eine
kugel eis für 0,7 lepper also 35 cent
das heißt wir sind hier beim zwölffachen
oder so also das natürlich ein
extrembeispiel aber das war echt krass
für mich in der schweiz also das ist so
heftig wird hätte ich niemals gedacht
ich hoffe es hat euch gefallen und ihr
konntet einen coolen einblick bekommen
ich würde mich mega aber noch nach oben
freund abonniert sehr sehr gern den
kanal leute und wir sehen uns zunächst
wieder drei leute